GORDON RAMSAY: I
can hear that beast.
LONELY: Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
Loud and clear.
I've been fishing in
some remote places,
but never in front of
an audience of hippos.
I'm constantly looking over,
because those things charge.
Lonely--
Yes?
That thing's getting closer.
Yes, I can see it.
We are safe for now.
GORDON RAMSAY: Are you sure?
LONELY: Yes, yes.
GORDON RAMSAY: Lonely, I'm
three times heavier than you.
I don't move that quickly.
Yes.
I can see they run
faster than you.
GORDON RAMSAY: Trust me.
I am not leaving here until
I catch a decent fish.
LONELY: Yes, yes.
GORDON RAMSAY: Come on, bass.
I'd like to catch
a [bleep] fish.
Come on.
Oh.
I think I've got one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No.
No I haven't.
- You missed it.
- No, no.
He's on.
LONELY: Still on.
GORDON RAMSAY: He's still on.
LONELY: Yes, yes.
Pull it back slowly, slowly.
Good.
Oh.
You see?
GORDON RAMSAY: Now that
is a good one for the--
- For the chief.
Right.
GORDON RAMSAY: Now Lonely may
have caught the most fish,
but let's be honest.
I caught the biggest.
I want to save my
fish for the chief.
So I'm taking one of
Lonely's back to Zola.
She might assume
that I caught it.
But if you don't say
anything, I won't either.
Zola.
Hey!
We are not empty-handed.
Oh, look at that.
I'd like you to scale and
gut that guy for me, please.
GORDON RAMSAY: Scale and gut it.
ZOLA NENE: The point
here for the week
is to hone your Zulu
warriors skills.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
ZOLA NENE: Braaing
is quintessential.
We're keeping it very
plain, very simple,
just a little bit of seasoning.
The ingredients speak for
themselves, generally.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
ZOLA NENE: Which is,
you know, in line
with tradition, in terms of our
flavor profile of Zulu people.
GORDON RAMSAY: Gotcha.
So here I'm making
something called ushatini.
It's a combination of
onions and tomatoes,
chopped up, which I've got here.
And I've been mentioning
to you how, you know,
the Zulu palate is
very simplistic.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
ZOLA NENE: But KZN is
the biggest population of
Indian people outside of India.
We do add a touch of
chili every now and then.
Right.
Because that sort of
culture has infiltrated
throughout the region.
GORDON RAMSAY: So no oil?
ZOLA NENE: No oil.
No, no oil.
Remember, this is
Zulu warrior cooking.
Sure.
There was no such thing as
olive oil available, et cetera.
So you just went
straight on to the fire.
- Straight on?
- On to the fire.
Yeah.
So wherever you see the
coals at their whitest--
GORDON RAMSAY: There.
--you'll know that they're
the right temperature.
There you go.
Good sizzle.
Wow.
What's becoming very obvious
is that it's very simple--
That's it.
--this tribal cooking, in a
way that it's a huge emphasis
on the fish and the meat.
ZOLA NENE: Yes.
What's the big
no-nos for the chief?
Zulu people in general do
not like their meat rare.
I know--
- Damn.
--you know, you're
Gordon, so you're going
to want to give them--
- Damn.
--medium raw.
What would happen if
you just try and suggest
he takes it medium rare?
I don't know.
I've never heard anyone suggest
anything to the chief before.
But you could be
the first, Gordon.
GORDON RAMSAY: Beautiful.
ZOLA NENE: Beautiful,
fresh piece of fish.
GORDON RAMSAY: Wow.
ZOLA NENE: Right on there.
- Oh my god.
ZOLA NENE: Hang
onto that for me.
And then I'm going to pop the
shatini on top of the flesh.
GORDON RAMSAY: Amazing
how simple it is.
And you think of
the fierce warrior,
in terms of what he stands
for, how important he is,
and look how simple that is.
That's it, simple.
Delicious.
Good fishing.
GORDON RAMSAY: That's delicious.
ZOLA NENE: Hmm.
So good.
GORDON RAMSAY: But so simple.
ZOLA NENE: So simple.
All the ingredients
speak for themselves.
I will see you--
I'll see at the end of the week.
At the end of the week.
Any tips?
Mostly listen and learn.
GORDON RAMSAY: Right.
And always remember, the
chief is a hard man to please.
- Gotcha.
- Good luck.
Thank you.
It sounds like I'll need it.
[laughing]